there's five ways to make serious money
in the world
okay
um
setting aside inheritance setting aside
winning the lottery
being a really black really good
blackjack player setting aside poker
the five ways most people
acquire their wealth and the fifth is
probably going to be the number one
c-suite jobs
and all that means is you get yourself
in a position where you have c in front
of your job title
ceo
cfo
coocto
right
c suite jobs pretty straightforward
most of them will pay you
into the six figures and sometimes seven
figures depending on the size of the
company
annually and if you're with a publicly
traded company you have the option to
earn
could be options could be stocks
there's quite often a lot of benefits
to see sweet job holders okay your card
needs to have c on it ceo cto cfo
something like that okay you have to be
a top level executive if you want to
make serious bank in most corporations
so there's that number two
medical professionals
um now this is going to vary from
country to country i can tell you right
now medical professionals in canada
don't make nearly as much as they do in
the united states
medical professionals can make quite a
bit of bank in the u.s so
the more
specialized your role is
okay the person that sits as a medical
professional and opens up an envelope
and then puts it in a tray and hands it
to somebody
maybe they're a medical professional but
they're not making bank okay the more
specialized your skill is
and the greater the demand is for it the
more money you're going to make
simple as that you're a
spinal surgeon that deals with a certain
demographic
um and there's only four of you in the
united states you're going to make some
serious money
okay so you can consider that if you
like dealing with blood and guts not for
me
um
another one number three so we've got
top level sales
you're selling
i don't know bugattis you're selling
yachts you're selling jet planes
uh to private uh
you know buyers to sports teams to
you know sheiks in dubai i don't care if
you're selling expensive [ __ ] you're
making a percentage commission of each
sale of each transaction real estate
okay you're selling you know seven eight
figure nine figure real estate i don't
know is there a nine figure real estate
out there maybe but you're going to be
making some serious ass money okay top
level sales
so if you're if you're extroverted if
you like talking to people if you like
net networking if you see the good you
know people you enjoy their company
top level sales man take a look at it
all right number four
top level in stem
so don't get a worthless degree
aaron cleary has a book
on amazon which you should read called
worthless degree
understand
worthless degrees are a waste of your
time
top-level stem is what you want to look
at if you're going to go for
post-secondary education you want a
university degree college degree
whatever it's it's called in your
country
if you're
science technology engineering maths and
another one that's paid really really
well the last few years too is um
programming writing code
um you know it falls under stem of
course but um writing code is a
very well paid profession
um i've had consults with guys that work
at facebook
youtube google
apple um high level executives and
guys that write code can make
750 000 usd a year
so if you're in a second or third world
country i know for a fact that facebook
for example has recruited a lot of
[ __ ] guys that write code
from asia india pakistan places like
that
um you can move around if you have that
skill a lot of guys are like oh i live
in a [ __ ] country rich what do i do
i want to make some money how do i sort
this out
that's one thing that you can consider
now i'm gonna i'm gonna say this as well
too is you better like what you're doing
you better like what you're doing
because if you hate writing code
you are not gonna
you're not gonna go very far i'm just
gonna say you're not gonna go that far
and the fifth one
my preferred favorite
entrepreneurship
the vast majority of guys that i've met
my entire life even when i was a kid i
remember i had
rich friends
we were the poor people in a rich
neighborhood you know where i grew up my
parents basically bought the
the cheapest house in the
most
affluent up-and-coming neighborhood so i
had a lot of rich friends growing up
they drove jaguars mercedes
one of them had a lamborghini
and
i got to tell you they were all
about 90 of them
entrepreneurs
is what it is okay
um and and it's a really really
too to me i mean i've i've worked um as
an executive
in
one of north america's largest credit
collection companies
um i have very good friends that are
medical professionals
you know professionals in general we're
talking like medical
uh
legal you know law you know for example
um i have a couple of friends that sell
high-end
equipment
i don't know what they are exactly but
they sell
equipment for manufacturing and these
things are like
900 000 to a million and a half each
you know for manufacturing processes so
if you sell high-end stuff
right and there's always somebody that's
going to argue in the comments i
disagree with the sales stuff redman 007
right well if you're selling something
that's a million five
and your commission rate is i don't know
three percent five percent one percent i
don't care what it is you you throw a
couple percent on something that is a
transaction for a million five for
millie five you're going to be making
some money off that you you know just
make your sales and you're going to get
paid very very well
but entrepreneurship man i'm telling you
guys
i am telling you guys right from the
start
if you
are clever
if you can solve problems the most
important skill an entrepreneur must
possess if they are going to be
successful is they must be a problem
solver
they must be able to
create solutions to problems that show
up in their lives
so with that being said
are you a problem solver can you get
good at solving problems
and you don't have to have
a university degree in fact most of most
of the most successful if i'm being
honest
guys that are running their own
businesses
some of them didn't even finish high
school
you know
i've had a few of them on my plane to
win playlist a few times too
so
get like get familiar with some of the
other stuff that i talk about here on
this channel guys you know
i want to make sure that you're not all
consumed with chasing the girls
um i get it they're pretty
but
spending way too much time and resources
chasing the girls is
it gets exhausting to hear
um i did a um a live twitter last night
and i think it's called spaces or
something i don't know i just wanted to
try it out to see what it was all about
a lot of young men come on you know
asking questions there was a
16 year old kid
asking a question about a girl who he
thought was making up an excuse tying
into religion
i said well
what are your plans man like you know
what are you gonna be doing
and um
he had a gig to go play basketball he
wanted to be a basketball player you
know professional basketball player
and i'm like have you read my book yet
no my parents will let me read your book
they won't let me buy it they have
restricted my access to it by the way i
just put my book on gumroad today too
so if you're not familiar with amazon or
can't access amazon it's available on
gumroad it's linked
in my link tree which should also be all
throughout social media you should be
able to find it
anyway
so
you're spending way too much time
talking about the girls and zero time
talking about his career making money
making sure he's in the right location
it's it's always a distraction for you
guys and i want to remind you and i and
i want to emphasize this as much as
possible chase excellence not women
so those are the five things c-suite
jobs medical professionals top levels in
sales when i say medical professionals
i'm i'm all-encompassing professionals
okay professional designations lawyers
medical doctors stuff like that
top-level sales top-level stem
especially if you can get into
programming that's paying big bucks
right now and entrepreneurship
pick one
you